nous sommes ici dans la chambre du roy
la chambre de françois 1er le roi venait
à chambord environ 70 jours par an eye
quand il venait c'était avec toute sa
cour itinérante à l'époque plusieurs
centaines de personnes et tous les
meubles
la décoration actuelle a été pensé dans
les années 50 il manquait de données
historiques résultats des aberrations
comme se lit sur une estrade où des
tentures espagnol c'est un cheminement
qu'on veut retrouver pas seulement la
restitution d'une pièce en changeant des
éléments de décoration
oui on va changer des éléments de
décoration c'est indispensable mais on
veut aussi retrouver un cheminement
emmené le visiteur et lui permettre de
de vraiment se se glisser derrière la
cour de françois 1er
meublé chambord alors qu'ils étaient
vides la plupart du temps n'est ce pas
un contresens historique direction tour
au centre d'études supérieures de la
renaissance 70 chercheurs travaillent
uniquement sur le château conçu par
léonard de vinci
leur expertise est consultée dans le
projet d'ameublement de chambord c'est
totalement légitime puisque ça permet à
partir de ce réaménagement de ce remue
blement de comprendre ce que pouvait
être la cour lorsqu'elles étaient
présentes
on ne prétend pas reconstituer la
réalité c'est tout simplement impossible
alors c'est encore plus impossible pour
le cas de chambord car nous n'avons que
très très peu de documentation
en revanche nous avons d'autres cours
nous avons d'autres moments avec des
comptabilités avec des éléments avérés
sur françois 1er qui nous permettent
justement d'arriver à retrouver en
quelque chose qui ressemble qui est
proche de ce que ça pu être l'opération
de financement participatif meublé
chambord dure jusqu'à fin février
l'objectif est de collecter entre 100000
et 250000 euros